(upbeat music)
- One question that people ask me
is how do I apply creativity
to the presentations that I give?
And my secret sauce is to
come up with a visual image
that anybody, I don't
care if you're the adult,
whether you're a fifth
grader or second grader,
that you can grasp that concept,
and here's my favorite one.
So every single time you move your body,
there's whole bunches of neurochemicals
that are released in your brain.
And you've heard of these neurochemicals,
dopamine, noradrenaline, serotonin.
And so that's the fact,
but the image that I give
is that every single
time you move your body,
it's like giving your brain
a wonderful bubble bath
of neurochemicals that enrich your brain
that change that neurochemical milieu,
and that is the image that everybody
that comes to my talks leaves with
and inspires them a little
bit to move their body more.
So can you come up with that image,
that playful fun, but
factually accurate image
that conveys your message?
That will be your secret sauce too.
- Have you heard that the
bees aren't doing great?
Well, I've been studying
that and trying to understand
how their complex health issues
connect to a curious little parasite
that's in nearly every
honeybee colony worldwide.
it's called Varroa destructor, by the way.
Now, before I started
this study, we thought
that it was an open and shut case
that the parasite was
sucking out the bee's blood,
sort of like a tick on a puppy,
but I thought something more
strange might be going on.
The damage that it caused
just didn't seem like
the damage that would be
caused by blood removal.
The feeding process is super
difficult to see though,
so I had this idea.
I fed different color glowing food
to the bees in their pollen
and their sugar water
to color their organs specific colors.
Then when the parasite fed on the bees,
I could tell which organ it was eating
based on which color was
in its digestive system.
And it turns out they were
eating the bees' liver,
by the way, which is pretty weird.
But this kind of work
is actually pretty fun,
and it was definitely a
place where creativity
was rewarded in biology.
(upbeat music)